hi there reject nation I'm Craig Alva hi
I'm Paula Paula Deming is here with me
helping to cover some III trailers and
we were spreading out these reactions
throughout the week Paula speaking of
games and III and all that crap she has
her own YouTube channel where she does
Let's Plays on there talks about gaming
board gaming even board games video
games streaming on Twitch shred I stream
on Twitch just look for my name
twitch.tv slash Paula Deen yes come join
me for a blind let's plays and follow
her on Instagram she dresses in suits
it's not sexy anyway we're gonna watch
this new trailer called ghost will I or
depends on your taste
ghost wire Tokyo oh this is a brand new
game huh you know what yeah Peggy 16
[Music]
those look like real Japanese people
life looks liek
[Music]
oh my goodness oh my gosh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay
oh my gosh
[Music]
don't fear the unknown attack it that's
a good philosophy I should just apply to
my life
oh damn we got to watch like the
presentation or about it that looks so
creepy but cool that's what when all
those people I'm gonna nerd out over
just like the way it looked like the
effect please do like it looked so cool
the transitions I will never get over
how good in real videogame animation
looks now like some of it looks so real
it looks like people walking through the
mall and then just when they disappeared
and the way their clothes just their
empty clothes fell to the ground was so
cool oh the hand the fingers on like the
creepy guy whatever they are we don't
know cuz a trailer didn't tell us looks
like a twisted guillermo del toro movie
meets like traditional j-horror with
this action-adventure mix in between it
all you know as I've been getting into
anime a lot lately
nothing freaks me out more than j-horror
really gets under my skin and that stuff
just looks so insane to me but you got
this character who does remind me of
Hawkeye and I use that game and yeah the
effects do look mesmerizing I like the
mood and the tone of it all and I like
the attention to detail that when they
disappear the bodies disappear but the
clothes are offline
that's a cool detail to have in here the
same dog is in the Doge mean you seen
the Doge mean yes I might maybe perhaps
you're right about the transitions and
stuff but that one with there's just one
specifically where a head of the flowers
kind of bloomed and then withered and it
turned into like the fabric whatever
that the person or the creature standing
there please I have no idea what this is
about but it looked like they were sort
of cleansing the earth overpopulation
like kind of that vibe and because then
you get that left behind
you got some people left behind yeah
that's an apocalyptic rapture rupture
sure sure yeah spinal rupture rapture
then you got the flowers blooming in
life as well so it looked like they were
starting kind of a new cleanse for the
world I really want to know like yeah
what's the story behind this let's watch
let's watch the presentation that leads
into the tribe you want to hear her talk
- yeah yeah shut up Paulo let's watch
this
[Applause]
please welcome the founder of tango
GameWorks mr. Shinji Mikami I want an
announcer voice like that
tango gameworks
[Music]
say her back I'd like to start by
working my team in poker it's Monday
morning there but they are watching you
know whether us come here
[Music]
[Applause]
today I am excited to announce the next
day from tengo dos warrior torture after
books
[Applause]
it is an action-adventure game and what
you were fighting by normal enemy and
the greatest city of a supernatural evil
[Music]
understand people yelling out maybe
that's okay ghost Wyatt or kill serious
creative director at Danville
Kumi Nakamura yeah I'm excited to hear
her talking about the game
like presenters for presenters
look adorable see you big fish makes me
nervous
I do my best to speaking English Greg
yeah right
we are making a new kind of
action-adventure game it's survivor
holiday that we are known for Peter
vanishing in Tokyo you must find out the
one you will encounter conspiracies and
the apart you have to you have to
explore the world face challenges to
uncover the tunas and save humanity in
the game you will meet spits some with
tensioners some thinkers and survivors
that each have their own stories you
will need to ask yourself it is normal
or paranormal I asked myself this
question every time I go to darkest
[Laughter]
just kidding we are very excited let's
take a look okay that's cool I actually
did get some insight into that I liked a
lot of what you had to say about it yeah
so you're encountering different spirits
which makes sense now and maybe some of
them are good and some of them are bad
and you're using it to figure out like
what's happening and why are people
disappearing yeah it seems like they
obviously they're gonna bring Tokyo to
life I like when they put a spin on
places you can actually visit in the
world i watch the watch dogs trailer
which puts a spin on futuristic London
and then here you're gonna kind of bring
a fully realized world to life of
supernatural entities living amongst or
taking over inhabiting Tokyo which seems
like a really dangerous area but I like
that touch that she's put on it that
some of them are gonna be good and some
of them are gonna be bad it's not gonna
be black and white and there's gonna be
able to figure it out maybe
yeah the why - all this happening
there's gonna be a real mystery solving
element as well because this this could
have just been you go in there you jack
up some spirits and some cool boss level
modes it seems like the adventure
element is really gonna be felt
understanding the mystery making you go
out and explore and see what you can
find and piece together clues I'm
thinking from what you're finding or
interacting with I'm interested in the
fact that it's an action horror game and
not an action-adventure horror game and
not just survival horror I get scared
really easily it's a survival horror
sometimes is like too much for me it's
all happening to me but in action horror
you know like in like a Resident Evil or
something I feel a little more in
control what's going on because you can
fight back against it so I like that
yeah yeah I love survival horror games
to them can't be wholly escape it even
though she said there it's not gonna be
label a survival horror I find it kind
of difficult to fully avoid that
considering the landscape the situation
you got your main character yeah
involved in your main character does
look like a super badass is equipped
with some of his own powers of his own
so I can see how the action element is
more elevated here as opposed to just
purely surviving here just a regular
dude living alone in Tokyo yeah and I
also like the inclusion that she said
that sometimes
encounter people that you're not sure
are paranormal or not it's like there's
this whole like mysterious thing
happening not knowing like is this
person normal or yeah this a good spirit
or a bad spirit why are people
disappearing should I adopt this
abandoned dog what am I gonna feed the
abandoned dog what if I disappear
suddenly and then the dog is abandoned
how much of the dog is in the game
that's really the dog should be the
focus dogs gonna die it's just like all
the games dogs die already becomes a
little helper I love the cinematography
behind these cutscenes this looks
awesome I can see why there's a lot of
hype for it alright guys well are you
excited for ghost wire Tokyo leave a
comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation sure but
does that really count you know what
counts clicking the notification Bell
but does that really do enough no you
got to hit the like button
oh well that takes care of the real
rejects what about Paula Deming we'll go
follow her on YouTube and twitch holiday
me all the damage is also part of the
fan theory TV YouTube channel that's how
I found her why are you wearing the
Doctor Who shirt because I react to
Doctor Who on fan theory TV type that
into your youtube search bar go check it
out it's pretty fun sometimes spooky
someone's doctor who is spooky you made
a work yeah you made it relevant to this
video tied it all in together sayonara